würde ich sagen dass ich keine angst
habe würde ich lügen
afghanistans frauen in angst 20 jahre
nachdem die taliban besiegt wurden
bringen sie jetzt immer mehr teile des
landes wieder unter ihre kontrolle und
feiern ihren siegeszug im netz
die internationalen truppen ziehen ab
und die gewalt nimmt zu vor allem gegen
frau
szenen wie diese zeigen die alten zeiten
sind schon jetzt wieder da
für uns frauen ist völlig klar die
taliban haben sich nicht verändert
sie ermorden immer noch jeden tag frauen
überall im land sie werden ausgepeitscht
und verbrannt oder ihnen wird die haut
abgezogen
mein name ist julia held ich bin
reporterin und will herausfinden wie es
den frauen hier geht mit dieser angst
woher nehmen sie den mut für ihre rechte
zu kämpfen
auch wenn sie das hier jederzeit ihr
leben kosten kann unter verschiedensten
hashtags haben mutige afghanen den kampf
für ihre freiheit aufgenommen
mai red lion zum beispiel die
sprichwörtliche rote linie die nicht
übertreten sehen wollen
ich bin journalistin und werde das immer
sein eine rote linie ist mein stift das
recht in die schule zu gehen ist meine
rote linie
oder wer ist mein nehmen der kampf darum
dass sich afghanistans frauen nicht mehr
schämen müssen ihren eigenen namen zu
nennen
dass dies kein dreh wird wie jeder
andere das war mir schon klar bevor ich
hier ankam wie angespannt die lage aber
ist das merke ich spätestens jetzt team
besprechen
zusammen mit unseren beiden afghanischen
to use an schultern und nancy und jörg
christ der fürs zdf seit jahren einsätze
im kriegs und krisengebiete begleitet du
machst einfach nur hier an und unsere
kollegen in deutschland kontrolliert
erklärt mir die tracking app mit der in
den nächsten tagen jeder unserer
schritte überwacht wird
wir diskutieren die sicherheitslage was
wir drehen können und was zu gefährlich
ist wann wird den gepanzerten wagen
nehmen und wann besser nicht hier in
kabul kann es jederzeit eine explosion
geben deswegen ist es besser mit einem
gepanzerten wagen zu fangen
in herat gibt es nicht zu viele
explosion ja dort geht es ihr darum dass
du nicht aufwärts das gute ist du siehst
aus wie eine afghanin trägt ein kopftuch
und wir werden ein ganz normales auto
nehmen mit dem wir keine aufmerksamkeit
auf und ziehen auch helm und weste soll
ich zumindest mal testen meint ja
wobei ich mich ernsthaft frage wie ich
die im zweifelsfall so schnell an
bekommen würde so ein bisschen komisch
ist es schon in so einem land auch immer
zu arbeiten indem das zur
standardausrüstung schuckert etwas
mulmig ist mir schon zumute als wir uns
auf den weg machen
der verkehr in kabul ist unübersichtlich
die größte gefahr so genanntes dicky
bombe kraft bomben die einem irgendeiner
ans auto klebt wir treffen roger federer
27 jahre alt fotojournalistin sie will
uns mitnehmen kann einen ihrer
lieblingsorte in kabul
heuer hat wohl einen der gefährlichsten
berufe hier in afghanistan
journalistinnen und journalisten stehen
auf den todeslisten der taliban ganz
oben sie zeigt mir ihre lieblingsfotos
porträts von mädchen für die sie oft in
die entlegensten regionen des landes
reist sie wolle denen ein gesicht geben
die die taliban am liebsten in die
häuser sperren würden erklärt mir euer
dass sie selbst damit zur zielscheibe
der islamisten wird nimmt sie in kauf
wenn ich sagen würde dass ich keine
angst habe dann würde ich lügen aber ich
muss einfach stark sein
hier ist doch gut wir können wir halten
ein berg mitten in der stadt
von hier aus meiner habe man den besten
blick
außerdem sei es einigermaßen sicher
[Musik]
si
wenn ich wieder mal jemanden bei einem
anschlag verloren habe ein freund oder
kollegen oder wenn ich die nachrichten
sehr über die taliban und höre dass sie
gerade wieder zwei junge frauen getötet
haben
dann frage ich mich jedes mal was mache
ich noch werde ich die nächste sein
aber dann gehe ich trotzdem wieder raus
und siehe die menschen um mich herum und
es fühlt sich normal an
und ich denke es wird schon irgendwie
alles gut geht auch hier am straßenrand
von kabul sind es wieder die mädchen die
roja faszinieren und ich merke dass es
mädchen wie diese sind für die reihe
bereit ist ihr leben zu riskieren
sie sind die zukunft afghanistans
ich will nicht dass sie irgendwann alle
in einer burka stecken angst dass sie
demnächst jemand zwingen könnte ja sehr
ich werde ja später noch einmal treffen
sie will an ihrer homepage arbeiten und
die fotos der mädchen auf ihrem
instagram buchladen und ich will sie
fragen welche rolle spielt das netz für
sie bei ihrem kampf für mehr
frauenrechte
erst mal aber haben sultane die ich eine
andere verabredung wir sind auf dem weg
ins französische krankenhaus von kabul
denn eines ist klar die burka ist für
junge mädchen in afghanistan längst
nicht die größte gefahr
es ist gerade mal sechs wochen her dass
bei einem anschlag auf eine schule in
kabul über 80 junge mädchen ums leben
kommen die taliban bestreiten etwas mit
dem attentat zu tun zu haben
die bilder der blutverschmierten
schulbücher aber gehen um die welt
sie werden zum symbol für die angst dass
es wieder einmal junge mädchen sind die
zu den größten opfern radikaler
islamisten werden
vor dem krankenhaus warten wir auf
familie akbari mit einem gemieteten
kleinbus bringen die eltern ihre schwer
verletzte tochter zu untersuchen
auch sechs wochen nach dem anschlag kann
die 17 jährige noch immer nicht wieder
laufen
nur mit viel glück hat fatima den
anschlag überlebt die schweren
verbrennungen werden für immer zu sehen
sein
noch immer stecken splitter in ihrem
körper und ihrem kopf
wie oft sie schon hier waren ihre eltern
können sich nicht erinnern
sechs mal schon wurde die tochter
operiert eine hilfsorganisation die
behandlung komm du schaffst das
[Musik]
die letzten male dass vertipper hier war
hat sie geschrien vor schmerz ich bin
gerade aus dem unterricht gekommen als
es die erste explosion gab
ich habe gemerkt dass mein rucksack
angefangen hat zu brennen
ich habe den rucksack auf den boden
geschmissen leute wollten uns helfen und
dann kann die zweite explosion und hat
uns durch die gegend geschleudert
sie hatte so schreckliche schmerzen und
ich konnte es kaum aushalten sie so zu
sehen
auch die verletzung ich bin so froh dass
es jetzt besser geht auch fatima wollen
wir noch einmal treffen
wir werden sie zu hause besuchen denn
eine frage geht mir nicht aus dem kopf
wie kann man jemals wieder unbekümmert
in die schule gehen wenn man weiß dass
es menschen gibt die einen dafür töten
wollen
schulunterricht nur bis zur grundschule
burka zwang und ein verbot ohne
männliche begleitung das haus zu
verlassen so sah das leben der frauen
unter der herrschaft der taliban aus
schon für kleinste vergehen lackierte
fingernägel zum beispiel drohten
drakonische strafen wie finger
abschneiden
mehr als 50 des landes haben die taliban
schon jetzt wieder unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht
seit beginn des abzugs der ausländischen
truppen erobern sie jeden tag neue teile
des landes die sicherheitslage wird
immer angespannter
überall checkpoints roth blogs und
zäunen das krasse ist das über kabul die
ganze zeit so nah hat berlin fliegt mit
einer kamera das heißt die stadt wird
die ganze zeit gefilmt ob irgendetwas
verdächtiges passiert
[Musik]
aber sind es die gleichen taliban wie
früher oder sind sie wie sie selbst
behaupten längst nicht mehr so radikalen
eine frage die sich wohl fast alle
afghaninnen und afghanen zur zeit
stellen wir kriegen hier ja auch im
moment jeden tag so e mails travel alert
heißt es informiert uns darüber welche
bezirke die taliban unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht haben und wie viele anschläge
ist moment so gibt von denen wir in
deutschland überhaupt nichts mitbekommen
ich will ein gefühl für die menschen
hier bekommen und will wissen wie sie
die lage sähen am liebsten würde ich
durch die straßen und über die märkte
laufen und sie einfach danach fragen
aber die sicherheitslage lässt das nicht
zu erklärten schultern
ich merke dass er angespannt ist und
auch hakim der sicherheitsmann der uns
die ganze zeit begleitet drängt uns
wieder ins auto zu steigen
auch hier jetzt an dem ort an dem wir
stehen sind wir nicht sicher
es kann immer eine bombe hoch
ungefähr an einem ort bleiben dann wenn
er das wir gehen und das ist ihr zu
also
wir haben
[Musik]
ich frage mich ja die ganze zeit ob
social media den frauen hilft sich zu
vernetzen und in ihrem kampf für mehr
freiheiten oder aber am ende eigentlich
ein größeres risiko bedeutet um auf
diese frage eine antwort zu bekommen
machen wir uns auf die reise nach herat
in den westen des landes nahe der
iranischen grenze
wir nehmen das flugzeug der landwirt ist
zu gefährlich die taliban haben dort
längst überall die kontrolle
wir werden unbegleitet reisen und auch
ohne gepanzerten wagen in herat würden
wir mit solchen sicherheitsmaßnahmen
eher auffallen
bei unseren recherchen sind wir auf
einen hashtag gestoßen
der ist sogar geschafft hat das
afghanische gesetz zu ändern
lange osmani hat mit der online kampagne
wer ist mein name bewiesen wie viel das
netz auch hier in afghanistan verändern
kann
doch der preis den die 29-jährige dafür
zahlt könnte größer nicht sein
es ist tradition dass wenn frauen
erwachsen werden dass ihr name nirgends
mehr auftauchen darf
nicht auf den rezepten die der arzt ihr
ausstellt nicht auf ihrer eigenen harz
einladung oder ihrem eigenen grabstein
stattdessen steht überall nur mutter von
xy tochter von xy oder frau von xy
auch im ausweis durfte bislang immer nur
der name des vaters stehen nicht der der
mutter kindern wurde beigebracht dass es
eine schande ist den namen der mutter
auszusprechen aber die kampagne von lage
und ihre mitstreiterinnen hat es
geschafft vor etwa einem jahr hat
präsident afghani ein gesetz
unterzeichnet mit dem auch der name der
mutter künftig im ausweis stehen darf ab
juli können die dokumente geändert
werden aber dann auf einmal der strom
ist weg cup holen angriff der taliban
bisschen außerhalb der stadt und jetzt
ist er leiter otto jetzt erst wird mir
wirklich klar die konkrete bedrohung
durch die taliban längst ist und wie
groß die gefahr für lahde und die
anderen frauen
sie haben gefordert dass sich die
kampagne stoppt als ich das nicht
gemacht habe haben sie mir dieses bild
geschickt von diesem mädchen in kandahar
dem sie die haut abgezogen haben mit der
drohung dass ich genauso enden werde
[Musik]
die angst ist da die ganze zeit das
merke ich und trotzdem wollen sich lage
und die anderen nicht einschüchtern
lassen
auf einem kleinen markt vor der tür
wollen sie andere frauen von ihrer
kampagne überzeugen
kennen sie unsere kampagne uhr is my
name' haben sie schon von where is my
name gehört die taliban sind nur noch
etwa 100 kilometer von der stadt weg
dort haben sie schon alle bezirke
erobert wir rechnen jeden moment damit
dass er hier sein werden
auch wenn sie die stadt noch nicht
erobert haben es gibt schon jetzt jeden
tag hinrichtung in der stadt und land
steht auf ihrer todesliste wir müssen
deshalb jeden moment damit rechnen dass
sie ermordet wird
selbst wenn wir diesen kampf nicht
überleben wie kämpfen wir auch für die
anderen die nach uns kommen damit sie
wenigstens eine bessere zukunft haben
sie sind bereit ihr leben zu opfern und
mir wird klar ist es nicht nur mut der
lage und die anderen herleitet es ist
auch das gefühl dass alle anderen dieses
land längst aufgegeben haben
wenn wir nicht aufstehen und kämpfen
wer tut es dann keiner hilft uns so
viele länder waren hier und sind wieder
abgehauen
ihr wart es doch die uns gezeigt haben
was freiheit bedeutet
sonst müssten wir ja gar nicht wie sich
das anfühlt 20 jahre lang waren wir frei
und jetzt fühlte sich an als würden wir
wieder zurück in unsere käfig gesperrt
sie fühlen sich im stich gelassen merke
ich und auch ich bekomme das gefühl als
habe die welt afghanistan und auch diese
frauen irgendwie aufgegeben zurück in
kabul
wie wenig unterstützung die afghanischen
frauen hier im eigenen land zu erwarten
haben das werde ich auch bei meiner
nächsten begegnung merken
ich hatte sultan gebeten uns ein treffen
mit einem namen zu vereinbaren
die stimme der religiösen gelehrten hat
gewicht in den eher traditionellen
bevölkerungsgruppen und ich möchte
verstehen wie sie den kampf der frauen
für mehr freiheit sehen
[Musik]
bevor ich aussteigen darf soll ich aber
erstmal mein kopftuch fester binden
sollte deine haare nicht sehen
salam aleikum ich bin julia
[Musik]
lollar ii schah mohammed ist seit vielen
jahren als imam in dieser kabuler
moschee er hat in ägypten studiert gilt
als besonders angesehen hat er
verständnis wollen wir von ihm wissen
für die angst vieler frauen ihre hart
erkämpften rechte wieder zu verlieren
und für ihren kampf auch mit den mitteln
von social media
[Musik]
es gibt doch überall im land so viele
frauen die regie ohne ihre männer oder
andere familienmitglieder verloren haben
und auch die wünschen sich alle nichts
anderes als frieden
diese anderen mit ihren oft
unrealistischen forderungen die
gefährden doch auch für alle anderen den
frieden
heißt also erst der frieden dann die
frauen so der imam lächelt und gibt mir
eine sehr blumige antwort die nichts
anderes aussagt als dass er das thema
frauenrechte für ein minderheitenproblem
hält und die kampagnen im netz für einen
fehler
also der war supernett hat man ja auch
die ganze zeit in die augen geschaut was
mich irgendwie überrascht aber klar ist
auch der hat jetzt nicht wirklich das
gefühl dass beim thema frauenrechte
irgendwie hinaus bedarf es seit
september 2020 für die afghanische
regierung offizielle friedensgespräche
mit den taliban
zwar wissen dabei auch vier frauen mit
am tisch zusammen mit dutzenden männern
wohlgemerkt das thema frauenrechte steht
aber bislang nicht mal auf der
verhandlungs liste und der versuchte
anschlag auf eine der teilnehmerinnen
fausia kufi zeigt wie sehr die frauen
unter druck stehen ein bisschen habe ich
im nachhinein das gefühl als habe der
imam versucht die frauen gegeneinander
auszuspielen und so zu tun als würden
lage und die anderen nur für eine
minderheit im land sprechen
wie dringend nötig ihr kampf aber ist
das wird mir klar als wir die verletzte
fatima april zu hause besuchen die
familie gehört zur gruppe der sache eine
schiitische minderheit in afghanistan
ohne viel rechte und ständigen
bedrohungen ausgesetzt
vor allem durch sunnitische extremisten
die akbari sind arm
zusammen mit den sechs kindern leben sie
in einem einfachen leben haus das die
kinder zur schule gehen dass sie es
später einmal besser haben
das ist ihnen wichtiger als alles andere
ich will wissen wie es der familie jetzt
geht nach dem anschlag mit welchem
gefühl während die eltern ihre tochter
demnächst wieder in die schule schicken
und vor allem was denkt fatima selbst
ich bin selbst nur bis zur dritten
klasse in die schule gegangen und kann
nicht lesen und nicht schreiben
ich weiß nicht mal wo eine toilette ist
weil ich die schilder nicht lesen kann
das haben wir für eine wahl als unsere
kinder in die schule zu gehen
auch wenn wir jeden morgen nicht wissen
ob sie zurückkommen
jedes mal wenn die kinder das haus
verlassen habe ich furchtbare angst um
sie den anblick als sich fatima nach dem
anschlag da so liegen sah es war
schrecklich
fatima sei eine gute schülerin gewesen
erzählt die mutter
während sie der tochter ein bisschen
frisches obst aufschneidet um sie
schnell wieder fit zu kriegen
fatima wie geht es dir wenn du an die
schule denkst hast du angst nein ich
habe keine angst sobald ich wieder
laufen kann will ich wieder in die
schule gehen
ich will auch eine journalistin werden
so wie du während sultan und ich uns auf
den weg machen muss ich an meine tochter
zu hause denken die zerrissenheit von
fatimas eltern die ihrer tochter zeit
die chance geben wollen auf bildung aber
jeden einzelnen schultag um ihr leben
fürchten
ich merke dass ich keine vorstellung
davon haben wie sich das anfühlt
am nachmittag treffe ich auch heuer noch
mal mit einem freund sitzt im café auch
das ist kabul ein ort der freiheit
hinter mauern an denen uns keiner nach
unserem kopf fragt zusammen mit dem
freund arbeitet reihe an ihrer neuen
homepage
und sie hat das bild von dem mädchen
gepostet oder sie vorhin gemacht hat in
meiner welt wächst du nicht den krieg
auf hat sie darunter geschrieben in
meiner welt wirst du nicht ermordet die
kidnappt oder ins verderben gezwungen
nicht viel von ihr wissen ob sie glaubt
dass solche post etwas verändern können
dinge die in anderen ländern vielleicht
kleinigkeiten sind für uns hier haben
sie eine riesen bedeutung
social media hat uns mutiger gemacht es
ist ein medium mit viel macht und großem
einfluss nicht nur für uns frauen für
alle menschen auch roja kennt die
drohungen aus dem netz und sie weiß dass
weder post auf eine gefahr bedeutet und
trotzdem ist da dieser unerschütterliche
wille sich von der angst nicht nehmen zu
lassen
das leben hier in afghanistan ist eben
einfach gefährlich
je weniger man darüber nachdenkt desto
ruhiger lebt man
ich habe vier tage hier in afghanistan
verbracht und unfassbar beeindruckende
frauen kennengelernt
über die frauen auf der straße
allerdings habe ich nicht viel erfahren
schon wenn sie unsere kamera gesehen
haben haben sich die meisten von ihnen
weggedreht
ich weiß also nicht genau welche
hoffnungen und ängste sie haben aber ich
bin sicher dass royal alle und die
anderen hier auch für ihre zukunft
kämpfen
ich glaube wenn ich gehe sich
interessiert eure meinung schreiben
gerne
[Applaus]
[Musik]